that there's a there's a fundamental
disconnect in the way that the world
views are being approached
and this is like if if anyone consider
themselves
uh essentially a conservative uh this is
the thing
you really have to bear in mind um
the the intersectional left which are
the
the people who that that's an umbrella
term that will broadly describe
black lives matter feminism anti-far you
know the
other communists you see on tv um and
people who are parroting the same
talking points in the same way
as them uh they have a view
of a human being that's just very
different to your own
uh most i i i'm gonna get a little bit
esoteric here but like most people
uh have a kind of unitary view of a
human being the human being is you know
you are your body you have
certain properties that are created by
your body which your strength how high
you are how tall you how [ __ ] you
jump
and it also includes your brain and
people understand the brain's a
biological organ
and that's the source of your
consciousness your will
right and so most people will understand
that there is a biological connection
between what you think and what you are
and you'll you'll notice in
like your moods you know you you see
people when they take uh when they
transition they start taking hormones
they speak about their dispositions the
way they feel
becomes different and that's totally
normal because the brain is a biological
uh piece of uh you know part of an
organism and it's affected by reality
and so most people don't think that the
will
has like this this sacred
sovereignty and the the will is being
constrained by the body
most people just kind of and without you
know without articulating like this but
that's the assumptions that they'll make
is that you know you you've you're
you're all a part of a biological
organism
but if you look at left-wing philosophy
at the moment it's oh i've got some
wrong way around anyway
um the if you look at left-wing
philosophy at the moment they they take
a totally different approach
like what what is it for a a regular
person
to identify a woman they'll say an adult
human female right
but that's a transphobic definition
because that
means that it can't simply be that a
person identifies as a woman
to be a woman and that's a very very
interesting dichotomy because
adult human female is very much based in
biology it's very much based in the the
presence of a person you know it's an
objective category i can look and see
that you're an adult i can see you're a
human i can see you're a female
or i could check if maybe um but i i can
objectively determine that however
what you choose to be is only in your
head
and it grants license to the idea that
the thoughts the consciousness
are somehow the supreme sovereign over
everything that's the most important
thing
um and i don't and i realize that
this is a very esoteric way of looking
at it but what that does is it makes it
transcendental it means it's not
connected to the biology the biology is
actually
holding it back rather than being a it
being a product of the biology
and so you end up getting people saying
well if i if i will that i am a woman
one day then i should become a woman and
it's like okay
i mean i i don't know i'm not trying to
be mean or anything
and i know that i agree that gender
dysphoria was
is a you know a problem that a person
has
but that doesn't mean that the will is
just correct you know
we it's it's there is a biological
process
that has not gone right to produce that
result
because it's an imperfect system but the
will itself
just cause it you know there's
conditions that make it feel a certain
way it's not completely free
and so we can't just treat it as
autonomous right but they are treating
us as a thomas i will that i'm a woman i
will
then this i will not say yeah okay you
know you can say that
but you know objective reality
has a different opinion and the the the
big schism
between the two is whether you are a
kind of person who believes in objective
reality which means or rooted in biology
and rooted in
things that we can touch or are we
actually
you know sovereign wills that are
trapped within this fleshy form
you know so that's i i i realize that's
that's probably
it sounds silly to people who aren't
really thinking deeply about all of this
but that's essentially
the philosophical basis i think the
manifestation of the will the
manifestation of that inner soul somehow
that is
what it is yeah um well just to explain
very
very yeah like it comes basically from
continental philosophy and it comes
essentially from the idea that the will
that
there
can be a perfectly good will and a
perfectly good will can only be
something that's not contingent on
reality because it would
have to be true in all times and places
basically um
and that it's a it's a very uh
continental way of looking at it and
it's not a very british way of looking
at it
it's a very idealistic way of looking at
it uh but the
the english-speaking world has always
been very empirical
and not really given to tremendous
flights of fancy
um and that's essentially the the major
difference that we're looking at here
and so it's not a surprise that the
english-speaking world is looking at
this thinking what the hell is going on
because it doesn't make any sense to
them you know it's
it's it's uh it's annoying
[Music]